Excellent.
[Music]
There's been a massive amount of hype
and anticipation around the AMD Radeon
RX480 launch. So, now that we can
actually review the cards, let me give
you guys the short version right up
front. The RX480 is a very good graphics
card for $200 or $240 for the 4 or 8 gig
versions, respectively. Its performance
is in the GTX 970 range, and it has some
compelling next-gen features to improve
VR and asynchronous compute performance.
It's not going to beat a GTX 980 or 1070
unless maybe you get two Radeon RX 480s.
And I'll think about doing a Crossfire
video if you guys maybe think about
hitting that like button. And it's
pretty darn quiet at stock fan speeds as
well. Overclocking is possible, but not
a ton of headroom. And yes, there will
be benchmarks later in this video that
have overclocking numbers and all that
good stuff. But first, the card itself.
It's black. Got some red accents on
there. Nothing too blingy with the
reference RX 480. No lights. Design cues
were taken from the Fury and Fury X
line, and I actually think I like it.
It's pretty subtle. It could use a back
plate, though. But, uh, some add-in
board manufacturers like F XFX and
Sapphire are already outfitting theirs
with them, or so I have heard. The
shroud is made of black plastic with
glossy parts where the red Radeon logos
are, and a rubberized panel across the
front with a grid of dots across it for
some texture. The PCB seen from the back
is short, which means we could see some
very small versions of this card in the
future. The rest of the card's 9.5 in or
242mm length is taken up by the blower
style fan with its metal housing. It's
open on both sides, so you can kind of
see through it like my facade of
calmness and composure. The GPU beneath
that cooler is the Polaris 10 XT. It's
based on brand new GCN 2.0 14 nmter
finfet architecture. It supports 234
stream processors, 36 compute units, up
to 5.8 teraflops of raw compute
performance, and just a 150 watt board
power. Hence only requiring a single six
pin PCI Express power connector. The
card I'm using today has 8 gigs of
256-bit GDDDR5 memory at 8000 MHz
effective clock speed. Video outs are an
HDMI 2.0b and three display port 1.4s,
meaning support for very high
resolutions and refresh rates like 4K
120 Hz, as well as HDR displays via that
display port connection, which can
display way more colors than standard
dynamic range displays. So, this card is
ready for nextG monitors. AMD has a lot
of technology wrapped up in the RX 480
and of course you still get support for
legacy stuff like FreeSync and Vulcan. A
new feature called frame rate targeting
control allows you to set a maximum
frame rate limit for games like CSGO
that don't need a lot of GPU
performance. That's just to save power,
which seems like a good idea, but let's
quickly talk about asynchronous compute.
Asynchronous just means out of order,
basically. and it's allowing the GPU to
dynamically handle different tasks like
graphics or GPU compute without having
to wait for one or the other to finish.
The Polaris architecture has dedicated
hardware called asynchronous compute
engines which are specifically designed
to do these tasks at very high speeds.
Since VR naturally has a lot more
asynchronous compute tasks involved,
such as headmounted display tracking
that needs to be updated very late in
the processing pipeline, having
dedicated hardware available means the
RX 480 has better than expected VR
performance for its class. VR
benchmarking is still in its infancy,
but the Steam VR performance test can
give us an idea of where these cards
stand, and the RX 480 is well within
that green zone for fully VR ready. I
overclocked my RX 480 by 5% and I got
the memory up to 8220 effective clock
speed. I did this with Wattman, the
overclocking utility that's built into
the Radeon Crimson software, which has
come a really long way in the past year
or so. It's a lot cleaner. The UI is
pretty easy to figure out, and you can
use the Wattman utility that's built
into it to assign specific overclocking
profiles to different games.
Overclocking itself is handled by
adjusting a frequency curve with
different overclocks and voltages
available for each power state. You can
use a slider to adjust the curve as a
whole, or in manual mode, you can assign
different frequencies and voltages
independently. You can also control fan
speed and temperature based on target
and max values. There's a power limit
option, which is down in the temperature
section for some reason, which was kind
of confusing at first, but I figured it
out. And there's a nice histogram at the
top that shows GPU activity,
frequencies, temperature, and fan curve.
It was enough for me to use for
monitoring during my OC testing. So, I
think the Radeon team has done a pretty
good job here. My only complaints would
be that I'd like to see unlocked
voltage. You can't go higher than the
1,150 molt max setting that it starts
off with. And it's also in need of a
profile system so you can quickly save
and load overclocking settings. At last,
it is time for benchmarks. Here's my
5930Kbased test bed system specs and the
cards I'll be comparing the RX 482.
Choosing comparison GPUs is not easy for
something like this, but ultimately I
decided that the GTX 970 and the GTX 960
4 gig would be the closest competitors
on team green. And uh I threw the 1070
in there just because I wanted to see
where the upper tier cards were sitting
by comparison. Remember the 1070 costs
twice as much as the RX 480 right now.
Since I have stock and overclock numbers
for the RX 480, I chose all aftermarket
cards for the Nvidia Competition that
have healthy, reasonable, but not insane
overclocks from the manufacturer. I also
have included 4K numbers just to see how
the 480 performs, even though it's more
suited for 1080 and 1440 gameplay in my
opinion. Time for some benchmarks.
So, what have we learned from these
benchmarks? Well, first, the RX4 all
over the GTX 964 gig, and it hangs
pretty darn close to the 970 and even
beats it in a few games. The 970 also
shows its limitations when using 3.5
gigs of VRAM or more, such as in the
Hitman benchmark scores, and several
other 4K scores as well. Tomb Raider,
Ashes of the Singularity, and Hitman are
all DirectX12 titles shown here as well.
And while the differences weren't stark,
except for maybe in Hitman, which is an
AMD Gaming Evolved title, which might
have something to do with it, I think
the Async Compute bonus did help the 480
pull out a few more wins over the 970.
Temperatures were normal for the 480.
And by normal, I mean they hit the
target temperature of 80° C. Peaked at
83°. Not the coolest running card, but I
can see potential for third party
coolers to help with this. And the fan
noise, even at that temperature, was not
bad at all. As for frequencies, pretty
much every GPU that I tested throttled
frequency to some degree, except maybe
the 960 after warming up to max
temperature. The RX 480 overclocked hit
1330 MHz, but only fell off maybe 30 to
60 points under full load with about the
same result at stock. Not bad, but I'm
really curious to see how fast the 480
could run with better cooling. As for
fan noise, I was quite pleased with the
stock profile, and AMD was true to their
word that they didn't want a noisy
reference cooler. Unfortunately, I had
to ramp up the fan to get any reasonable
overclock going. So, here's a listen to
the fan at idle.
Here's
the fan under load, still using the
stock profile.
Here's the fan set manually to 70%.
And here's the fan at 100% where yes, it
does get quite loud.
Finally, some power draw results. And
given the performance, I am happy to say
that Radeon has really stepped up when
it comes to efficiency. The RX480 does a
great job and is pretty much equivalent
to the 970. It's conclusion time. I kind
of started this video out with a
conclusion, but to reiterate, very good
graphics card for $200 to $230.
Compelling nextG VR and async compute
features, pretty quiet, okay
overclocking. I think the only way you'd
be disappointed with this card is if you
were reading all the articles or
watching all the pre-launch hype videos
talking about it beating the 1070 or 980
and running at 15 or 1600 plus MHz. The
price is great and it needed to be to
hit Nvidia where they were lacking that
substantial gap between the 960 and the
970. The cheapest 970s right now are
still $260 plus and I think that price
will definitely be coming down to stay
competitive. Even if that happens, the
extra VRAM, the VR readiness, and the
hardware async compute features of the
RX 480 would still make it a very tough
choice. And hey, one last plus for AMD
is stock availability, as these cards
should actually be available everywhere
today, launch day, so you could actually
buy one, which is helpful when you want
a new graphics card. If I were to ask
for more, I would have liked to see it
overclock a bit more, as I too read the
rumors and had a bit higher hopes. The
temps are a bit warm, too, but perhaps
with binge GPUs, aftermarket coolers,
and driver refinements that we should be
seeing in the coming weeks, we will see
improvements to those numbers. If you
are looking for a $200 to $250 GPU with
very solid performance, plenty of VRAM,
support for nextG displays and HDR, and
especially if you've been looking to try
VR, but you haven't been able to afford
it, I definitely recommend the RX 480.
Links to this card on Amazon, as well as
my Paulware store are down below, where
you can buy shirts and stuff. Hit the
like button definitely if you enjoyed
this video and get subscribed. And as
always, thank you very much for
watching.